je sais qu'il est tard que tout le monde
est un peu fatigué a envie de rentrer
chez lui
voilà j'ai un message personnel à vous
communiquer à tous
avec des choses intimes parfois pas
facile à dire bon voilà j'espère que
vous me pardonnerez c'est la première
fois l'espace de 10 ans 8 ans 8 ans que
je me laisse aller à cet exercice voilà
donc je j'avais quelques éléments à vous
partager et à vous dire
hey on y va c'est bien première fois que
j'écris mon texte
je suis arrivé au Mureaux voici des armé
14 ans j'ai eu un vrai coup de coeur
pour cette ville que j'ai trouvé être un
bel exemple de vivre ensemble
certes ce vivre ensemble ne se déroule
pas toujours dans une harmonie parfaite
mais il me semble que pendant
l'essentiel des années que j'ai pu vivre
ici
la ville connaissait un équilibre une
certaine cohésion sociale c'est pour
cette raison que j'ai décidé de m'y
installer et dit fonder une famille car
cette intervention est d'abord celle
d'un citoyen inquiet du délitement du
lien social dans notre ville une ville
qui a changé récemment depuis deux ans
en me référant mon expérience
personnelle j'ai subi 11 agressions ou
moi-même ou ma famille nous sommes
sentis menacés jusque dans notre
intégrité physique là où pendant 12 ans
je n'ai jamais connu d'épisode de cette
nature
ces derniers épisodes je ne vous cache
pas ont été violents et ont profondément
remis en cause le lien que j'avais avec
la commune et avec ses habitants je me
suis vu reproché d'être qui je suis
ces épisodes et encore plus le dernier
en date ont été marqués par de la
violence verbale des masses physiques
allant jusqu'à la menace de mort et aux
insultes homophobes et racistes
le Blanc Kit ma vie on est chez nous ici
c'est ce que je me suis entendu dire
avant qu'on ne me poursuive jusque
devant mon domicile pour me menacer de
mort ensuite
oui les citoyens d'origine européenne
peuvent faire l'objet de racisme et
c'est un homme dont tout le parcours
politique s'inscrit à gauche qui vous le
dit